[Music]
wow
you should definitely go
[Music]
is that a glock in your pocket no what
it's two blocks
oh
[Music]
so if you cannot
[Music]
my name is sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys
and i live in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work
at the bank everybody
i thought i had everything i needed but
then
i met her everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something guy there is no easy way to
say this
this world it's a video game you're not
real
pleased
and the guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time now if that's not real i don't know
what it is
i know this world is just a game for
this place these people that's all i
have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy next
guy i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
that actually hurt my hand we can save
our world
but we have to fight together
[Music]
[Applause]
nope
i can't die
[Music]